this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out Squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them in just a bit when
Jack Churchill died in 1996 one British
newspaper said in his obituary that it
would have been impossible to invent him
because a fictional character with his
story would have just not been credible
but why is that what exactly is so
unbelievable about a man who charged
into battle in World War 2 wielding a
broadsword and who shot at Nazis with a
longbow this was a man who played his
bagpipes while his unit was making a
landing in enemy territory a man who
time and time again narrowly escaped
death because fortune favors the bold he
was also a man who but he was finally
done with military life he went on to
become a surfer truly there is nothing
weird about mad Jack Churchill a man
proclaimed by the Royal explorers club
as one of the greatest adventurers to
have ever lived and in the episode today
his story mad Jack was born John Malcolm
Thorpe Fleming Churchill on September
the 16th 1906 his father Alec Fleming
Churchill worked as an engineer and
later as director of Public Works which
meant that he moved the family around a
lot for his job Churchill first grew up
in the British colony of Ceylon which is
now Sri Lanka and then Hong Kong before
relocating again to England
Jack had two younger brothers who would
go on to have distinguished careers in
the military although not nearly as
colorful Churchill received his
education at the dragon school in Oxford
and King William's College on the Isle
of Man before enrolling in the raw
Military College Sandhurst
he finished military school in 1926
enjoying the second Battalion of the
Manchester regiment on deployments in
Burma which is now Mon Mar over there
Churchill didn't see a lot of action
mostly patrolling the Irrawaddy River by
boats to check up on all the villages
along the way he found various hobbies
to pass the time and this is when he
first started playing the bagpipes being
tutored by the pipe
the Queen's Own Cameron Highlanders a
regiment first raised back in 1793 he
also bought a Zenith motorcycle and took
if a road trips through Southeast Asia
he had a memorable but dangerous
encounter while riding across India when
he ran into a water buffalo for a while
it seems like Churchill's military
career would be a rather short and
unmemorable one after getting bored with
military life he retired from the Army
in 1936 he went on a grand tour of
Europe a company is barley another
former member of the Manchester
regiments who became a prominent soldier
in his own right by the name of rex king
Clarke Churchill took advantage of these
three years by putting one of his
greatest skills to good use and as
archery he took part in competitions
even representing Great Britain in the
1939 world archery championships in Oslo
Norway his proficiency even earns Jack a
few small movie roles where he portrayed
archers in films such as The Thief of
Bagdad and a Yank at Oxford
[Music]
Churchill enjoyed his time away from the
military but as soon as World War two
started he joins up with the Manchester
regiment again and was deployed to
France as part of the British
Expeditionary Force the BEF this is
where Churchill established his
colourful persona became known as mad
Jack or fighting Jack Churchill as he
was sometimes called the extent of his
quli era t shall we say is a batter of
some debate Churchill himself was never
wanted to to zone horn so most stories
they come from secondary sources when
you are dealing with the Grands persona
like that of Mad Jack it's pretty easy
to mix up myth with reality first off
there was the sort shall indeed carried
one with him because in his own words
any officer who goes into action without
his sword is improperly dressed it is
often said that Churchill favored the
Scottish claim or that is not strictly
correct though as we're not talking
about the famous large two-handed great
sword instead he wielded a smaller
one-handed version called a clay bag to
avoid any confusion here the main
differences between the two apart from
the obvious size was that the clay bag
had a basket held instead of a cross
hillsand was single edged unlike its
large counterpart Churchill probably
chose this weapon because it had been
used for hundreds of years as the full
dress sword for the officers of the
Highland regiments mad Jack did not get
to use his sword in combats he often
instead he relied on its a signal and
inspire the men as can be evidenced by a
photograph of a charged exercise in
Inverrary then there was the bow and
arrows Churchill certainly had the skill
to use them effectively and often took
them on patrols as they were a silent
weapon he is credited with making the
last recorded kill with a burn arrow in
World War 2 when he took down a German
soldier in 1940 finally to completes the
look mad Jack Churchill also carried a
set of bagpipes he would often play a
few rousing renditions before battle to
boost the morale of the men the march of
the Cameron men was a bit of a favorite
of this of course all of Churchill's
eccentricities would not have been
looked upon so fondly by as men if he
wasn't also a capable leader when he
joins the BEF he was made
second-in-command of the 4th Infantry
Brigade with the 2nd battalion his units
was part of the dial plan or plan D and
effort by the French army and its allies
to stop the German invasion
through Belgium this did not turn out so
well the allies kept losing battle after
battle and had to retreat while German
troops kept advancing westward
eventually this culminated in the Battle
of Dunkirk but before that Churchill and
his men had their own little moments of
glory in the tiny French village of
epinet nearish Bor why this point
Churchill was in command of the unit
because the original commander had been
injured in battle their goal was to
patrol the Maginot Line and secure the
Allied retreat on May the 27th 1940 mad
jack and two infantrymen were covering
the rest of his units when they saw a
small group of five german soldiers
approaching this was the infamous moment
when Churchill took out his longbow and
shot one of the enemies before his squad
mates opened fire with the more
traditional machine guns the reason this
is infamous apart from the obvious is
because different sources give differing
accounts some say the target was an
officer rather say that he was a soldier
some say that Churchill hit him square
in the heart while others claimed the
arrow went in the neck or into his
stomach some sources even assert that
the illustrious moment never happened at
all and the man Jack himself later
confessed that he had lost his bow
earlier in the campaign indeed if it did
happen then hitting the German sergeants
in the heart would make the most sense
Churchill was an elite-level Archer he
would have had the skill and forethought
to go for the most lethal shot on the
most valuable target during the fight
Jack took a bullet in the shoulder but
was also rewarded with the Military
Cross for his bravery he then fought at
Dunkirk where he sustained another minor
injury
[Music]
following the evacuation at Dunkirk
Churchill returned to England's but was
already eager to get back to the
fighting in 1941 he joins the British
commandos and took part in operation
archery also known as the Molloy raid
this was a British efforts to launch a
raid on German forces occupying the
Norwegian island of Orcs a Churchill was
dispatched with the number three
commando battalion where he once again
served as a second-in-command the raid
started in the early hours of December
the 27th unbeknownst to the Allies the
German side also had an additional unit
of light infantry Mountain troops called
kibbutz Ayako which were there on leave
this prolonged the battle and increased
the number of casualties but the British
they were still successful they took
about a hundred prisoners and freed
around 17 Norwegian resistance fighters
as well as sinking 15,000 tons of
shipping and obliterating strategically
significant docks warehouses and fish or
plants moreover if the Nazis wanted to
maintain control of the area they would
have to redirect troops which could have
been useful elsewhere
Churchill was in charge of one of the
five parties that the commandos were
divided into he led his men into action
with another stirring rendition of March
of the Cameron men afterwards he throw a
grenade took out his sword and charged
into battle now Jack sustains an injury
during this fight for which he received
another Military Cross the exact nature
of the injury however remains something
of a mystery it is possible that
Churchill was hired by a British
demolitions charge which detonated too
close to him in another version the
explosion caused the wall that Churchill
was leaning against to crumble and fall
on top of him in perhaps the most
fitting story during the British retreat
Jack liberated a bottle of wine to
celebrate their success again May charge
went off in close proximity and smashed
the bottle sending a shard of glass
flying towards Churchill Jack returned
to England to recuperate but he would
soon experience tragedy
six months later his younger brother
Robert he was left Tannen's with the
Royal Navy was killed in action off the
coast of Malta now just before we get
into Jack's next adventure I do you want
to take a minute to tell you a bit about
squarespace two simple things here
number one maybe you've got some idea in
your mind floating around for a website
or a business or a YouTube channel maybe
a podcast something like that I know I
always got those ideas floating around
in there and then the second thing the
only way to figure out if that is an
idea worth doing is to get it out there
in
world and I know this can be daunting
because it's scary to pursue new things
and we're all nice and comfortable just
carrying on doing what we're doing but
you know a website is not an excuse for
moving forward there are no excuses
available with Squarespace
Squarespace allow you to create a
powerful website for whatever you're up
to whether you maybe want to sell
something online do it Squarespace or
you want to have a podcast I've got a
podcast up I made the website with
Squarespace you can see that a brain
food FM took me half a day no excuses
maybe you're starting a YouTube channel
like me that's what I do
having a website to complement it is
important it all starts on Squarespace
with a beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content they
also say that I should mention like
starting from scratch but don't do that
just start with a template and just work
with that it's way easier no excuses I
want you going through the super easy
customization process there's no updates
there's no patches there's no tech BS to
deal with also Squarespace handle all
that website e stuff like I said they
handle podcasts you can also do mailing
lists social media stuff it all just
plugs in nice and easy like I said
Squarespace remove the excuses to your
dreams half-hour out get started just do
it now also 24/7 customer support
just head to squarespace.com for a free
trial when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com forward slash biographic
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain and let's get back
to jack seriously though just before we
get back to Jack just open up that link
in a new tab and go after this video
don't go browsing rounds on YouTube for
more stuff even from me just go start it
pursue your dream and let's get back to
Jack like I said
the newly promoted leftenant colonel
churchill was now in charge of the
number due commando battalion to which
she was assigned in 1943 in order to
take part in the Allied invasion of
Italy the unit first landed in Sicily
and then in Salerno
both times mad jack at his trademark
sword on his waist bow and arrows
strapped to his chest and bagpipes
underarm it was an unusual sight but
then again
Sehwa Churchill's tactics which
nevertheless proved effective although
Italy withdrew from the war the Germans
still had troops in the bay of Salerno
the Allies initiated operation Avalanche
with the goal of eliminating the Nazi
presence Churchill's commandos and the
task of disabling the artillery fire on
the western half of the babe during the
final counter-attack man Jack came up
with a counterintuitive strategy he knew
that the location made a surprise attack
impossible instead he went for the
complete opposite he organized his men
into six parallel columns they attacked
in the middle of the night repeatedly
shouting commando to avoid friendly fire
the battalion won the fight completed
its objectives since took 136 prisoners
that somehow Churchill's crowning moment
came afterwards Jack excelled as a
commando he liked to carry out stealthy
raids and counter-attacks leading small
teams of hand-picked soldiers one night
in Italy he went out accompanied by just
a corporal hoping they might run into a
German or two they did that spotted two
figures smoking cigarettes in the
darkness they were Nazi soldiers part of
a group digging trenches in the nearby
village of picolet II Churchill and his
corporal they snuck up and subdued them
taking one each mad Jack then used the
soldier as human shields and entered the
village with his sword drawn he went
from one small digging team to another
taking them by surprise and forcing them
to surrender in the end he took 42
prisoners and made them march back to
his camp dead and carry their own
mortars bombs and wounded to slow them
down
Churchill even allowed the soldiers to
keep their weapons but he did make sure
to remove all of the rifle bolts he was
further rewarded with the Distinguished
Service honour
[Music]
next up the Churchill was to take part
in the McLean mission in 1944 in
Yugoslavia the country had quite an
adept resistance force known as the
partisans which were led by Josip Broz
Tito and were causing plenty of
headaches for the Nazi war machine the
main purpose of the mission was to make
contact with the partisans find out all
of us to know about them and help them
fight the Germans however possible
fighting Jack and his commandos were
tasked with conducting a raid on the
island of brac specifically they wanted
to control vid over gora which at 2560
feet is the highest peak not only in
branch but in the entire adriatic
islands once again he led the charge by
playing the bagpipes as his men ran into
battle however the position was heavily
fortified including mines and artillery
only a few men Churchill included
managed to reach the objective and they
were also incapacitated by shrapnel from
mortar fire the reigning survivors were
taken prisoner what happened next was a
nice moment of serendipity or Karma
depending on what you believe man in
charge of the POWs camp was one captain
Hans thorne he always treated his
prisoners well there's a show of
gratitude shouts will regime a thank you
letter and even invited him to England
after the war to have dinner with him
and his wife
Shona kept the letter and it saved his
life later when he was captured by
Yugoslavia as war criminal during his
time as a prisoner Mad Jack moved around
a lot and this was mostly because the
Germans incorrectly thought that he
might be related to Winston Churchill
nope first he was taken to Berlin for
interrogation and afterwards he was sent
to the Saxon housing concentration camp
he was held in special campaign which as
his name would imply was reserved for
prominent prisoners of war Churchill who
was not there for long because he
started working on an escape plan almost
as soon as he arrived in September 1944
he and a small group of British officers
dug a secret tunnel and made their way
out among his co escapees was Royal Air
Force officer Bertram James he took part
in no less than 13 breakouts from Nazi
POWs camps during World War two
just a few months prior to this he was
among the men who escaped from Starlog
roof 2/3 and the events immortalized in
books and cinema as the Great Escape
so let's get back to Churchill he
sprained his ankle during the breakout
and while he never complained about it
it did slurm down he was recaptured near
the town of gusto and this time he was
sent to another prisoner camp and to
roll in Austria of course
Jack managed to escape again one night
when the floodlights were not working he
made his way through the Alps and into
Italy where he was found and rescued by
an American recon unit his time spent as
a prisoner did nothing to dull
Churchill's appetite for action the
Germans might have surrendered but the
Japanese were still waging war in the
Pacific Theater he went off to fight
them in Burma but by the time he had
reached India the Americans had dropped
the atomic bombs on Hiroshima and
Nagasaki and the Japanese forces had
capitulated half-jokingly
Mad Jack said to one of his friends that
if it hadn't been for those damned Yanks
we could have kept the war going for
another ten years
the second world war might have ended
but there were plenty of other conflicts
for a man like Jack Churchill he took
advantage of the more relaxed atmosphere
to fulfill some of his less important
military goals
he took parachuting courses and joined
the fifth parachute battalion
successfully executing his first jump on
his 40th birthday he also entertained
his love of everything Scottish by
transferring to the Seaforth Highlanders
and becoming a commander of a Scottish
regiment Churchill's the last bloody
moment in battle occurred in 1948 during
the final months of the British Mandate
of Palestine he was deployed as an
officer with the Highlands Light
Infantry 1st battalion at a time when
conflicts between Jewish and Arab forces
were common in the region on April the
13th the convoy of medical staff and
supplies escorted by members of the
Jewish paramilitary organization Hagana
was on its way to had us a hospital on
Mount Scopus in Jerusalem when it was
ambushed by Arab fighters Churchill and
his men were in the area and although
British orders were to stay out of the
fight he tried to evacuate members of
the convoy in an APC possibly apocryphal
but the story goes the mad Jack walked
alone towards the ambush smiling and
carrying a black thorn stick his
reasoning was that people are less
likely to shoot you if you smile at them
meanwhile the Highlands Light Infantry
provided cover fire but one of the
British soldiers was killed in a
shootout
Churchill's offer of help was turned
down out of belief that Haag enough
forces will come to the rescue with the
better coordinated efforts with one of
his soldiers down and his assistance
refused jack withdrew his men high
enough forces did not arrive in time and
two of the convoy trucks caught fire
killing 70
seven of the 79 people on board later on
judge will assisted with the evacuation
of how to sell hospital bringing around
500 medical staff and patients to safety
[Music]
Churchill's military career lasted until
his retirement in 1959 but the last
decade or so was significantly less
exciting than the escapades that
preceded it he spent this time mostly as
an instructor at various training
facilities such as the army apprentice
school in chepstow and the lands air
warfare school in Queensland Australia
Churchill's private life was in stark
contrast to his military service as it
was quiet and unassuming in 1941 he
married Rosamund Margaret Denny
granddaughter of Sir Archibald Denny a
famous naval architect together they had
two sons named Malcolm John Leslie
Churchill and Rodney Alastair Gladstone
Churchill during his years down under
Jack became a fan of surfing and
continued his hobby when he returns
England he had his final brush with Fame
in 1955 when he became the first person
to ride the wave of the river seven
afterwards he kept out of the limelight
until he died in 1996 and sorry at the
age of 89
Churchill avoided the headlines for the
last decades of his life but he still
retained traces of the rambunctious
young man who treated the Second World
War as one giant thrilling adventure
he kept busy by refurbishing steam boats
making radio-controlled model ships and
taking part in motorcycle speed trials
when he worked in London Churchill
enjoyed freaking out fellow train
passengers on his commute home by calmly
getting up opening a window and throwing
his briefcase outside but there's always
method to Jack's madness what the other
riders didn't know was that he was
actually hurling the briefcase into his
own back garden so they did not have to
carry it home from the train station so
I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and do not forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
just like this four times a week
also check out Squarespace like I said
if you're not open that tab now is the
time click below and thank you for
watching
[Music]